les gens sont gentils ici il faut se
méfier des apparences la ville de
saintes adeline ressemble à une petite
communauté paisible et tissée serrée 6
pas facile du tout vision de quoi gêner
mais un drame intime va bientôt faire
craquer le vernis espèce de silence de
on veut pas voir on voit des affaires
mais c'est c'est trop chaud ou c'est
trop et parent ou c'est trop ou c'est
trop se mêler de ce qui nous regarde pas
fait qu'on détourne le regard les nôtres
de la laiterie jeanne leblanc pas de
maternité dans toute sa complexité
est-ce que tu caches n'utilise pas
facile d'être parents qui souvent ce
qu'on montre à la télévision au cinéma
c'est soit des démarches terré coût des
mères mais rarement des femmes aussi
nuancé ans que nous elle désire une
bille qui se posent nos portes
donc on a tous des gens dont les
familles sont alourdies par des secrets
par des cons qu'ils osent pas confrontés
c'est à ça reste dans le non dit ça
reste on veut pas que ça craque nul pas
en garde au statu quo porté par une
solide distribution les nôtres confirme
le grand talent de la jeune emilie bière
passe passe dans l'erreur en est-il
échanger tout simple mais il faut que ça
parle ça va a besoin qu'on les entende
un mot
la milice est une force de la nature
j'ai dit jobs pendant qu'on tournait
mené j'ai dit c'est quand tu vas avoir
une grande carrière internationale
votre souvenir me voir quand je vais au
chez-nous des artistes a répondu c'est
quoi ça chez nous des artistes avec les
nôtres jeanne leblanc c'est une
véritable thriller psychologique tout en
demi teinte mais extrêmement troublant
après sa présentation au rendez-vous
québec cinéma le film prendra l'affiché
le 13 mars